the easiest place to start is actually
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's meant to be
informal it's meant to be non-edited
it's meant to be kind of behind the
scenes and so if you're trying to
develop that practice of being a speaker
of creating content I recommend starting
like Ground Zero you start with
Instagram stories and try to find three
to ten moments during the day that you
can share it's about starting to share
the way that you think to serve other
people you're weird you're different you
think differently your job is to teach
me to think like you think so some of
the things that may seem super obvious
to you for other people is not so
obvious right it's not going to be
perfect being off your phone and it's
not going to be the the lighting that
you want or the gear that you want or
the background that you want and your
thoughts may not come out as clearly as
you want that's the beginning the
beginning is supposed to be messy so
don't stress out about having all the
information at the beginning just go
just create in that momentum you will
start getting some results and
additional momentum to keep on building
the first question that came in on the
poll was how can we focus on one thing
with too much information
so at the beginning of anything
it always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which
um audiences and just testing tests and
testing testing until I kind of get a
sense of okay this is where the gates
are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
now it's Evan Evan's holding up to two
percent I got mine I got mine too make
the two percent happen anyway so I hope
that makes sense right it's taking that
big idea that seems overwhelming that
seems impossible and then finding one
step that you can do today because as
long as you have it as some big dream in
your head that is impossible then you
never take any action and then you know
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing yet because it still
seems too impossible and I see it all
the time with entrepreneurs who are
getting started people ask you how do I
get started on YouTube how do I get
started as an author how do I get
started as a speaker and and you think
you've got to have this perfect plan and
the perfect gear and all of this perfect
stuff and then it's a year later and you
still haven't done the thing immediate
action momentum I see Zayn's big smiling
um Dan joined me on my uh three days a
week now I stream League of Legends and
answer business questions and Zen joined
in and they said yeah I'm gonna start
making YouTube videos uh and I think it
was original timeline was like next
month or in two months or something it's
like dude Zen come on tonight make a
video let's go get get your video up uh
and then he did and he got his first
video up and then the second video and
then another video like he's got his
phone out he's gonna make another video
right now
like that's the process and and it's not
gonna be perfect being off your phone
and it's and it's not gonna be the the
lighting that you want or the gear that
you want or the background that you want
and your thoughts may not come out as
clearly as you want that's the beginning
like the beginning is supposed to be
messy so don't stress out about having
all the information at the beginning
just go just create like in that
momentum uh you will start getting some
results
um and additional momentum to keep on
building right and
I think a lot of you know my story about
losing that 40 million deal when I was
22 years old of just trying to be too
perfect and have it all planned out and
you know
going to Market and then seeing Oh My
Perfect plan was not what people wanted
anyway right like your perfect version
of a YouTube video is not going to be
perfect anyway once you start creating
it's going to change it's going to take
a million different turns
um so the best way to do it is to do it
so to take action against that big idea
so it doesn't just stay
uh doesn't just State an idea for you
forever okay next question Nicolette
said what is your advice on where to
start with content creation if you
haven't started at all
so the easiest place to start is
actually Instagram stories like easy is
easiest easiest way to start is
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's it's meant
to be informal it's meant to be
non-edited it's meant to be kind of
behind the scenes and so if you're
trying to develop that practice of being
a speaker of creating content I
recommend starting like Ground Zero you
start with Instagram stories and try to
find three to ten moments during the day
that you can share you know you where's
my book built the serve right you guys
you guys you have this book if you're in
this group right you've you've got it
hopefully you've read it it's not just
some fancy ornament sitting there on
your desk Zane's got two copies Victor's
got his copy
I love it Evans I know has got an entire
Shelf full of uh of books somewhere
there at the top
um
so you know it's it's about starting to
share the way that you think to serve
other people you you're weird you're
different you're I like to say you're a
weird duck you think differently your
job is to teach me to think like you
think so some of the things that may
seem super obvious to you for other
people is not so obvious right if I look
at even your your rooms for those of you
who can see you know your your rooms
like why does Zan have Captain America
shield on his wall you know why does
Evan have Napoleon Hill on his wall and
Andrew Carnegie Doug's Doug's trying to
hold up built to serve but it's being
blocked out by then by the Florida coast
uh you know why does Jeff have Steve
Jobs up on his wall right Michael's
showing believe up on his wall right
like why why do you have these in your
rooms in your offices it means something
to you and that may be like maybe maybe
Zan's been a Captain America fan since
he was eight years old I don't know like
maybe that's just so natural normal for
him but for other people it's kind of
weird to have a Captain America shield
on your door right like most people
don't have that so explain why it's
there right explain why you picked up
this book most people wouldn't know that
that's Napoleon Hill up on Evan's wall
right so explain why he's there explain
what that message means and finding
these micro moments throughout the day
from your your routines your habits what
you're eating for lunch what happened
when a client emailed you like the way
you respond to things is different and
so that's your job it's not about how
fancy the the video footage is it's your
job to teach me to think the way that
you think and sometimes this is hard to
step about it because for you it's so
natural and normal because you've been
doing it for a long time but for
somebody else who's watching you from
the outside it's it's weird and
different and that's the whole point and
so Instagram stories I think is the
easiest way to start just to get you
into that practice of creating content
again you know three to ten different
stories a day it takes 15 seconds Max so
you know at the minimum I'm asking for
45 seconds a day right this is not a
groundbreaking amount of time to create
content right 45 seconds three 15 second
stories a day
when you're ready to jump in and make it
much bigger
I would look at YouTube as my primary
home and then I would split up the
content to go to the different platforms
so when you can get to making one
YouTube video per week I want a 10
minute YouTube video every week and it
could just be taking me deeper right Zan
has a 10 minute story about the Captain
America shield Evan has a 10-minute
story about what he's learned from
Napoleon Hill Jeff has a 10-minute story
about what that Bullseye thing is behind
him right you know Michael has a
10-minute story about what believe means
to him right it's it's just taking me
deeper into it but the the Instagram
content stories is the first way to just
start practicing getting it
out of your head out of your mouth and
into the internet right into the world
um once you can get to 10 minute video a
week that's where I want you to be on
YouTube
because those that content will live
forever and then you split up the
content to go to all the different
social media platforms so until you're
ready to do that Instagram stories once
you're ready to do that then you can
still do the Instagram stories right
it's just add-on it's additive again the
Instagram stories are 45 seconds a day
everybody here has 45 seconds today to
record three Instagram stories to tell
me about something that's happening in
your life and and it's not this is
really hard for me at the beginning of
making content was it's not about
uh
telling me what you ate for lunch and
just kind of vlogging
it's trying to find a message in
everything so if you're showing me your
lunch tell me why you picked that thing
like why are you picking asparagus for
lunch or why are you having that Donut
for lunch like why why are you picking
that thing like explain to me the
thought process behind it right I'm
having the donut because I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday or something right like
I'm getting the asparagus because I have
you know I want to live a keto lifestyle
or whatever it is right like explain the
thought process behind the decisions I
remember when I first got started on
social Twitter was was blowing up and I
thought Twitter was stupid like this
looks so stupid people are just sharing
pictures of their lunch and cats and I
have no interest in just sharing I'm a
pretty uh private person believe it or
not like I have no need for you to know
what's happening in my life I have no
need to share it
but when I realized oh this is actually
thought leadership content that the
reason behind making this book or the
reason behind having these pictures on
my wall it's not about me showing off
it's about me trying to help other
people think the way I think so that
they can improve their lives as well so
everything you've got around you is a
story that hopefully has helped you
improve your life some way now bring
that back to bring not bring that back
into the audience so that they can learn
from you like why are you here why did
you pick up build to serve what was the
biggest lesson that you got from it all
of these could be individual stories
that again teaches people to think like
you think so Stephen wrote why is it
important to tell your story Okay so
and built the serve we talked about this
right
people need to connect to you
if they don't feel like you know what
they've gone through they won't listen
to you so
you know Evan has shared a lot about his
story with uh alcohol addiction and
you know you would look at Evan like
right now and you would say oh this guy
looks like he's polished and clean and
knows what he's doing and has his life
in order and you wouldn't necessarily
think that he was addicted to alcohol
and and I know Evan's okay with me kind
of sharing bits of his story here on the
Stream
so if somebody came and was struggling
with alcohol addiction and they came
across Evan and he said hey here's what
you have to do these three things
they say yeah that's great man but you
don't know what I've been through
you don't know what it's like you don't
you don't I mean I'm addicted you look
at you you've got your life together
it's all sorted out meanwhile Evan knows
exactly what it's like uh to contemplate
suicide to to be you know massively
addicted to have a lot of self-hatred
because of of the addiction of that
cause
and so unless people know what you've
been through they won't listen to your
advice like Evan has some of the best
advice to help people overcome it but
unless they know his story about how he
came through that they won't listen to
him
because people will naturally think well
you don't know what I'm going through
and so this is where you have to share
your story where you've came from even
the journey that you're still on right
we're still growing we're still learning
we're never done learning growing
getting better and improving but where
did you struggle where did you come from
because ultimately your purpose like we
talked about and built the serve is to
help other people who currently are who
you used to be
right there are many people who are Evan
from eight years ago
I have intense math we got two evidence
in the group I like using that as an
example right but there's also many
people who are Evan Carmichael from
eight years ago and that's who you're
talking to and that's who you'll love
helping the most you know Evan tinsman
will love helping anybody right and he's
been uh an amazing human in in the
movement makers group in this group even
when we first did our session in
Pittsburgh uh he was bringing value to
all the other people in the room he just
wants to help right he wants to
contribute which is fantastic
but helping somebody who
is currently struggling through alcohol
addiction is currently struggling with
self-worth is currently struggling with
uh potential you know suicide he'll love
helping those people more than holding
the door for somebody at a grocery store
or buying a Starbucks the person behind
him in line because that's who he used
to be and it's the same thing for all of
you and I'm telling I'm a story because
I know it better I don't know all of
your stories you know in detail but
you've all been through something
and those are the people who you're
going to love helping out the most it
just feels so much better it feels so
fulfilling that you represent hope to
them that when they see you
and what you've come through
it represents possibility for them
because they don't see possibility for a
lot of you where you are right now is
impossible
for where Evan is right now it's
impossible he shouldn't be here he
shouldn't be doing the stuff that he's
doing right now it's impossible Evan
from X number of years ago would look at
this kind say there's no way you're
going to be doing that that's not
possible
but he did it yeah and so have you and
all of you are here right now and the
version of you five ten years ago would
say that's not possible and so that's
your job is to show other people who
currently are you from five or ten years
ago that it's possible that there is
hope that you can grow that you can
overcome that you can climb out of this
hole that you're in
but without sharing your story to the
question that Stephen asked without
sharing your story uh nobody's gonna
listen to you so you've got all this
great information you've got the
knowledge the tools the the desire to
help the willingness all of it and you
can help and you know that it can help
but nobody's going to listen to you
because they feel like you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't been through what I've been
through right
so that's why it's super important to
share your story and and um it's scary
it's scary to share your story it's
scary to put it out there it's scary for
people to know
um what you've been through you know
like using Evan against an example he's
has a super successful uh practice uh in
insurance and it could be scary to let
that out to have clients have customers
have Partners have people in the
community know that you almost killed
yourself and you were addicted to
alcohol right like now you're not normal
anymore now you don't fit in maybe as
much anymore it could be scary for
people to know what you've been through
um
but if you are silent it perpetuates a
silence it means everybody else who's
struggling with it they stay silent too
and they become afraid to share and your
willingness to share to be brave to be
courageous to put your story out there
inspires other people to say hey I'm not
alone I'm not the only one going through
this and it's okay to share my story too
so I see that as your all of you your
responsibility to be able to do that so
okay Esmeralda is here how do I overcome
the fear of being in front of the camera
or sharing pictures of myself well
where's Esmeralda Esmeralda we could do
it right now it's called turning on your
camera
hey we got lots of people hey there she
is Esmeralda
it's one side look at all the high fives
and fist bumps and flexes you're getting
right I mean that's that's the start
uh so I do a couple of things one
is I tell myself that being afraid is
not a good enough reason
you don't want to teach yourself that
I'm afraid and I don't do it I'm afraid
and I play small I'm afraid to chase
down my dream and then I don't go for it
because that becomes this negative cycle
that we repeat and I love that you're
like in a in a grocery store or
convenience store somewhere there well
they're all still tuning in to the live
it's amazing uh but being afraid is not
a good enough reason if you can catch it
like the reason I want to do this but
I'm but I'm afraid that just mental
break down that wall being afraid is no
longer a good enough reason because
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of what you're afraid
of
every growth every opportunity every
breakthrough every client like
everything you want to do comes from
doing things that you're afraid of
otherwise if you're never afraid then
what then you you stay stuck doing what
you're doing you just stay inside your
comfort zone it's just you're live
photocopying every single day
are you at your job that's amazing I
think she's working there it's awesome
Esmeralda joining in
I remember when I had my one of the only
jobs I had was doing data entry at this
company and they wouldn't let me listen
to music so it was back when we had a CD
what's a CD man it's like the Walkman
but for CDs like a portable little CD
player so I used to have that on the
floor and then I ran a wire through my
jeans and I always wore a turtleneck and
I ran I got an extra long extension cord
for my headset for my headphones and I'd
run the wire under my turtleneck and
just pop out here to get one little
sound Bud to go into my ears so I can
listen to some uh mostly Andrea Bocelli
at the time while I was doing this super
boring data entry work so I love it I
love I love the hacks
um okay so to that question one is
fear alone is not a good enough reason
the second part is you're trying to
serve you're trying to serve you want to
help you're doing this you know you're
afraid to get in front of the camera but
why do you want to get in front of the
camera
take it from I want to it's not about
you being seen it's not about you being
this big famous name it's about you have
a message that can help people you're
here trying to serve and whenever I flip
it to it's about the audience it's about
the people who will see this is that
even if only five people see this video
maybe two out of those five people this
could actually be something
life-changing for them
it's not about you it's about them
that always gives me that extra little
bit of of confidence and push to go off
and do the thing that that I'm afraid to
do so I balance it between those two
things right I'll tell myself I'm Evan
christili Carmichael I do difficult
things or I do scary things or I do the
things I'm afraid of Plus
I'm here to serve and I'm here to help
and my message
can hopefully Touch Somebody Today it
may not but it's your intention going in
like the intention behind the action of
being in front of the camera is not to
screw people over it's not just to make
yourself famous it's to try to help us
to try to serve
and so I always take that mindset going
in before uh whenever I'm super nervous
uh or before never making any piece of
content it helps when you're when you're
even filming your own YouTube videos
because sometimes it's hard when you're
at home in an office maybe with Corona
you haven't seen any humans for the last
little bit and interact with them and
you just even here I'm talking just into
a camera and it's awesome to be able to
see your faces up here on the screen
to remind yourself that hey this is a
video that's not just me in my office by
myself you're making this video to try
to touch somebody else's life and when
you take that as an intention your video
will be better
when you just focused on oh am I looking
at the camera and is my mic set up and
all this other stuff your video won't be
as good compared to if you actually
picture somebody
in your head I used to do this all the
time because I had a hard time getting
to the zone and I was making content I
would picture somebody and I'm I'm
making this video for him this video is
just for him and I'm speaking to him and
and that would Channel him as I pressed
record on my camera and I'd always end
up getting a much better video man time
flies it's crazy we've already got time
let's get to let's get to like super
rapid fire
uh uh how to deliver the idea message in
a simple way
uh oh hot chocolate readings I would I
would do a 30 second hot chocolate
reading every day and post it to
Instagram
hot chocolate reading of the day and
then whatever whatever the whatever
comes at every day right every day for
30 seconds
um from Denise what type of videos go
viral in your opinion if you know if I
had a recipe for making a viral video
every time
that'd be amazing like that's what
everybody's going after but really be
looking at
make the video that you from five years
ago badly needs right make the video
that the you from five or ten years ago
badly needs because the youth from five
or ten years ago probably wouldn't watch
an Evan Carmichael video
like oh that guy he's too energetic he's
too positive that can't be real I don't
know
you know like you don't want to listen
to those guys
but
you could you could touch you from five
or ten years ago in a way that Evan
Carmichael or Tony Robbins or Brendan
Bouchard or whoever else can't
and that's I think even much more
important than worrying about a viral
video that that blows up on the Internet
is having an impactful video that
changes somebody's life
so I'm still trying to make the content
that
uh that I need right now but also that
like five years ago Evan still needs so
that's always kind of in the back of my
head as well
I haven't since been saying disagree ooh
okay your content helped get this event
to where he is now
well I love it thank you everyone
appreciate the love man
um loved that five to ten years ago idea
brilliant yeah just to imagine you
from five or ten years ago or somebody
who is like you and you're making
content for that person because you know
again Jeff from five or ten years ago is
thinking a different way he's not
doesn't have as much of a growth mindset
is
not wanting to listen to a lot of the
messages that are being put up there you
know he would look at what you're doing
now so that's crazy you know with books
on the shelf and Bullseye and all these
goals and accomplish like you wouldn't
think that that would be possible uh and
so you can reach Jeff from five or ten
years ago in a way that nobody else okay
so the topic was from Mark Elwood hey
now Mark does productivity and time
studies but but his question is about
encouraging return visitors to the
website for make me a poem so
um while well it's good that you're here
so we can kind of Workshop it uh
can people do the idea is that they're
going to make their own poem and then
share it with you or what's the concept
well here's the deal yeah you I don't
want this to be all about me so I'll
just do this briefly and then you can
talk about websites in general for those
who are in that kind of business so just
very briefly uh everyone do try this
afterwards because I'd like your input
make me a poem.com you go there and you
can create your own poems just by
filling out some questionnaires and for
those of you who are into
self-development there's one on motivate
yourself to get more done there's one on
uh getting yourself out of a slump and
you can do one for your partner your
love partner and others after one free
poem then you're asked to register
there's no payment yet so I'm interested
in getting your feedback collectively uh
so make me a poem.com it's fun it's
really kind of neat try the one for kids
too there's sound effects and pictures
so
um we've I've just started four weeks
ago we launched the registration two
days ago people are making about 30
poems a day we're getting five or six
sign ups a day so Evan that's enough of
that you can talk to the group generally
about attracting people to your website
about gamification about uh getting
monetizing a website it doesn't have to
be just about me you can talk in in
general terms cool yeah and listen
welcome everybody I made this group so
that people who've read the book can get
value and actually start to execute in
the ideas so we do this every week uh
either me if I'm here or Zane when when
I'm not because importantly that you
actually take action and don't just have
another book sitting on your shelf
um what I love doing in any kind of
business model is trying to figure out
how do I get people to come back in
terms of how do you incorporate this
into a regular routine so you know the
idea of make me poem is great and just
looking at the at the website uh I think
expressing why this matters like why
should I do a poem would be helpful so
you give the cases of motivate yourself
or write a love letter to your partner
but something something about the the
importance of it
people don't default the thinking poems
like I don't remember the last time I
wrote a poem at all so uh I mean it'd be
good with words I've written some books
so I don't know but but having that be
something aspirational of
why poems are important and they could
be famous quotes and people talking
about poems uh the the value of having
connections all that kind of stuff but
so the why and then how do we build how
do we build what we do and this is
beyond the websites for everybody you're
trying to build your movement how do you
build what you do into somebody's
routine
so if I'm if writing the poem is the
thing how do we incorporate a weekly
poem or a daily poem or a 30-day poem
challenge to find the 30 people that
we're most grateful for in our life and
send them a poem and we don't know how
to do it so that we've got this great
tool to help us figure out how to do
this
right so giving giving it some kind of
challenge or some kind of opportunity to
help it build into their calendar maybe
it's the charges even afterwards so do a
five-day challenge or seven day
challenge of picking five to seven
people that you want to recognize in
your life
and some coming back and I'm doing that
every day and then at the end of that
challenge then you have the option to
pay and upgrade a membership or whatever
else
um
I think the more you can incorporate
that so you know for me I have we're
doing a series right now our main
channel the billionaire mindset series
it's a 30-day challenge or every day for
30 days
we're showcasing Knowledge from
billionaires so you want you want to
think like a billionaire for 30 days
join the challenge right there's an
email sign up there's a PDF calendar
companion calendar that goes along with
it it's all free but gets people into
the system so you have your first poem
for free great
what I see it as oh this is a cool
one-off
because there's nothing that's hooking
me to want to come back so that
challenge of
if you said think of the seven people
that you're most grateful for in your
life and you want to recognize them
and then you're giving me prompts like
your spouse your boss your employees
your team your family give me a list of
100 people that I could think of your
high school friend the guy you met in
the Starbucks in 2006 you know or those
kind of things yeah on that briefly uh
the next one I'm thinking about is one
on appreciation you may only have one
lover in your life but you got a lot of
people to appreciate so that's probably
the next one the next poem that I'm
going to build
yeah or or I mean some of these might be
for yourself right I mean you said the
first one is motivation for yourself so
pick one for yourself pick one for
people in your life pick one for friends
I think the more you can involve other
people too I think it's especially
valuable if I write a poem for myself I
may not feel as powerful as I write a a
love poem to Zane
[Laughter]
you know and even even if it's a funny
one it's gonna get a reaction right and
then oh now that Zane saw it he's gonna
give me something back and it's gonna
reinforce the the feedback loop like oh
this is this is cool
um but you mentioned you mentioned the
word challenge is that the sort of the
new gamification we talked about getting
Badges and things way back but now
you're talking about challenges as well
what that's evolved to
um yeah I mean gamifications still isn't
it's not dead you can still have
challenge uh Badges and points and all
that stuff it's kind of complicated to
to set up versus if I came here
and I signed up for something that's
seven days instead of just a one-off I
don't know in your head it's not a
one-off
the idea is people come here all the
time and keep doing this as part of
their regular routine but if I'm landing
on this page I just feel like it's a
one-off that I might do for somebody and
so that's that's the challenge for you
is to say no this is something that you
should be doing regularly and here's
here's how you get started so you make
it super easy to get started so give me
a list of seven people one is for
yourself I would probably do like day
seven the last one for myself I want to
involve other people as soon as possible
if I made a love poem for Nina and she
freaks out that's gonna that's gonna
reinforce my belief that this is
valuable
and I'm going to come back the next day
and do something else
so but people need help just like they
need help writing the poem they need
help thinking of who to send this to
so I need a list of types of people
right
load your high school yearbook and find
somebody yeah like you can give a list
of a hundred different kinds of people
that you could send a poem to
and then that becomes a challenge for
the next seven days
um is it sent through your system
or they have to say it themselves we can
we can build something we're talking
about building something where we would
email the poem to someone okay right now
you just download it yourself
got it
um
yeah so even if even if they put in
their email address like how they have
the poem emailed to you that if I type
it in then a poem gets emailed to me now
you have my email address so that you
can send me future stuff
um I think yeah I think it'd be valuable
so I mean it's for everybody too whether
you're doing poems or something else
somebody's landing on your piece of
content how do you hook them to want to
join you for
a set number of days because if I'm
coming back every day doing something
for a week I'm much more likely to stick
I'm much more likely to talk about it
and the more you can involve somebody
else on day one versus motivate yourself
to get stuff done like I'm gonna send a
a letter A poem of appreciation to
Mark Elwood and he writes back says how
amazing that is the more you can connect
people together the better
um one of the new things I'm doing to
movement makers so if you join movement
makers we created a new onboarding
sequence where you join movement makers
uh I send you a video DM to say hey
welcome to Movie Maker so excited to
have you can't wait to have your next
training and I'm following you back on
Instagram welcome board
um somebody just wrote back today to say
I can't believe you sent that personal
message I'm in tears I appreciate you so
much like that took me 12 seconds to
send that video DM
but she's already a lot more interested
in what we're doing what happens in next
week is I'll then send another video DM
to introduce them
to the man I sent to Zen and the woman I
sent to Angela
so uh a new woman joins I say hey Susan
welcome makers again I want to quickly
introduce you to Angela Angel's in the
group she's been with us forever she's
awesome I want you to connect on a quick
Zoom call one so that you don't feel
alone when you come to move makers your
first meeting you're not by yourself you
have somebody to connect with and two
just to help you get the most out of the
program she can answer any questions not
a sales pitch you're already in but she
can help answer any questions you got on
how to get the most out of this
membership and so that's a that's maybe
you know three videos takes me uh 45
seconds to save that message and send so
now they have somebody else they both
have somebody else that they know so
that when they enjoy movement makers
some people are stressed out overwhelmed
like oh my god did I do the right thing
but then they see Zane think oh yeah I
talked to Zan last week he was amazing I
can't wait to go on it's not just me
they're hearing from it somebody else
who's already in the community and So
the faster you can get connection to
others Beyond just you
it increases adoption it increases the
Habit so
back to the Palm website the first thing
I would love to do is have my first poem
be to whoever the most important person
is in my life
and maybe that's my I mean for me I'd be
Nina but it could be uh my parents it
could be my my children it could be my
partner if it's pick somebody like who's
the most important person in your life
and that's the first poem that I send
and hopefully I get a little emotional
doing it and they get a little emotional
in receiving it and now we've created a
new habit Loop that we want people to
jump into cool
good topic good topic okay what else we
got we still got we got still got some
time before Zane takes over what do you
guys got
good question Evan yep
uh views on YouTube you and I have
talked about this before with my YouTube
channel I have a utility Channel yep
teaching people how to pass driving
exams yes yes
we're just about to hit 200 000
subscribers wow look at that congrats 30
million views we're honing in on 30
million views awesome so just a quick
overview so since I'm not really after
subscribers I've I'm in the SEO game as
you said which was the light bulb going
on in my life in your life wow okay
great
well it was it was like well which is my
business right my business life I guess
yeah
um so what's a quick overview of how to
get more views how to get more eyeballs
on my videos in YouTube without getting
subscribers
it's all about the keywords for you so
uh were you I'm trying to remember were
you doing by state or was it just
generic that's what I'm working on right
now is the state stuff I'm implementing
that it took me a little while to get
going on that but I'm currently
implementing that so we're going after
those keywords of how to pass the
driver's test in California Texas for
yeah
yeah so definitely definitely the big
the big States first and then working
your way down to all of them I don't
know if it matters for
for cities
like I would I would go and let me just
type this in so you're you're smart
smart
drive test yes like can we find you
smart drive test the other thing I've
done recently with videos because I put
one video up a week
I've been going to my competitors yeah
and looking at their most uh their most
popular videos yeah and doing those
topics and that's been that's been
successful
so how to pass the road test
so yeah so I mean it's popping up BC
Alberta for me because I'm Canadian
that's what it's funny that that's
showing up before Ontario which is my
state so looking at this right you have
New York and then you have NY
road test in 3D driving class I don't
even know what that is I don't know if I
want to know what that is it's like a
simulator yeah do you do that you cover
that too oh I don't cover simulators I
don't think that I my personal opinion
is they don't work okay well you can you
can make a video on that
um so these are the big like New York
Massachusetts Florida Georgia and
Minnesota like you're taking these exact
keywords but then the next level down is
stuff like this like how to pass the
road test in Wayne New Jersey
okay and and there may be no difference
you know like what's the difference
between Wayne New Jersey and New Jersey
it could be exactly the same thing right
but from a search perspective this is
this is weird advice it's something that
most of you shouldn't follow because
Rick as much as he's got 200 000
subscribers actually doesn't care about
subscribers this is a pure SEO play so
the keywords matter
um so you know if I type that in I don't
know what shows up
like this guy has 385
000 views on this video with 600
subscribers yeah
I don't know what raw raw way is is that
a is that a city in New Jersey uh I
don't know
I haven't heard of that no I'm curious I
get to dive into all these yeah it's in
New Jersey right so because he made this
video like this should be you
okay he made this video that put Rahway
in the title and he's got 385
000 views on this nothing Channel just
because I put in Wayne New Jersey that
video but that video Evan is also five
years old that's fine
so but like you said we could definitely
do that yeah I mean but there'll be lots
like Railway seems to be
you know a title is interesting
um yeah that's fine that it's old
uh it's still it's still being
recommended yeah yeah no you're you're
absolutely correct and and the beautiful
thing is like has things changed that
much in the past five years that really
warrants a new video probably not the
only thing in the last five years is
backup cameras
okay so great this is why this video is
still crushing for them
this guy's business probably isn't even
let's see what is he doing
oh he's doing he's doing some other
videos so he's teaching people how to
drive a lot of these are too short
50 seconds one minute
um but yeah so I mean we just found this
because I put how to how to pass the
road test
and then that popped up
so
you just said these are too short what
do you mean by Too Short
I'd be looking at I mean for him at
least five minute videos if not eight to
ten to 12 minute videos explaining you
can even repurpose a lot of the content
Rick
yes
slightly different videos hey if you're
I would start with the thing if you're
looking to pass your test in Wayne New
Jersey I'm going to show you how in this
video and then the rest is the same
video
[Laughter]
because it's all the same stuff like
it's it's New Jersey
but but you hooked me in in the
beginning where this thumbnail says uh
uh Wayne Wayne New Jersey on the
thumbnail and you say that in the intro
and then that's a different enough video
for YouTube as long as there's something
slightly different uh all I have to redo
is just reshoot the 20 second intro
yeah now if there's actually difference
between New Jersey and California then
fine then then
you know again it's a slight difference
the only the difference is that they
don't parallel park in California they
back up 50 feet along and curb so that's
the only difference right so you could
be popping out 20 videos a day all on
different cities
and then when somebody's searching
you're gonna you're gonna be that guy
that shows up because they're searching
for their own they feel like Wayne New
Jersey is different
even though you know that it's not they
don't know that it's not
so this is this is the other piece that
I have planned Avenue as soon as this
covet thing is over and I can go back to
the States I'm going to just travel to
the top 10 states in the U.S and I'm
going to do a driver's video in each one
of those States and then I can like you
just said I can repurpose each one of
those videos
to nail all 50 states
yeah but I mean you could you could
start now and just do a version two
okay
timing uh Evan did you think that you
need eight to 12 minutes to teach
someone properly or are you talking
about the uh YouTube algorithms and
algorithms algorithm yeah I mean it's
algorithm it doesn't matter so much for
Rick because he's going so long tail
that
like I put in Wayne New Jersey and and
the railway New Jersey video popped up
because YouTube's smart enough to know
that Railway is close to
Wayne somehow right there's not enough
there's not enough people making content
so he could probably win with shorter
videos but in general if you're making
longer videos it does it does better on
YouTube I would I would make I would
it's not just to teach it's to actually
rank better in the algorithm so what
were you aim for uh Evan on yours
we're going for an hour oh okay yeah
like we're going long but I would say at
least 10 minutes and what's great about
Rick's thing is
it's the same video so you could you
could do it you could do a 10 minute
video make it really good or 15 20
minute video make it really good people
will watch if you're teaching them step
by step like put put an effort into
really making it good like the best
thing and there is not a lot of good
quality anyway on it so it's not that
hard to be the best but I would hire a
videographer come with you make it high
quality
and then you can even just cut pieces if
you just took some some
um random streets that doesn't look like
anywhere you don't have to be in
California it could just it could be
anywhere some random street where you
don't see the street signs and oh that
doesn't look like Wayne New Jersey or
whatever it's just totally could be any
any city in America any side street
um and then film there and make that
your base and then if you have to splice
in or out content around okay well
California we're gonna do parallel
parking and that gets cut in
and you're going to take that part out
for New Jersey
and the other thing Evan just on that
comment about longer videos yeah I was
looking at one of my competitors this
morning their most popular video was an
hour and 14 minutes
oh yeah
that's just going over multiple choice
questions for the learner's test yep and
it's got almost a million views in a one
year
yep I'm like okay I need to do this
video
right and then do it by State even even
if it's the exact same questions people
will think it's different because
they're going to YouTube to find yeah
I don't know what it is weird about that
with a mental block I have about that
doing the exact same video but saying
this is for New Jersey this is for
California I I have some mental block
with that I don't know what it is maybe
it's my upper limit problem
no you're you're just flip it to service
you're helping people this is what
people are searching for and there's not
enough content on it the the good news
is you don't have to make it fancy or
because there's not a lot of content out
there on this people aren't really
committing to doing it so you could win
with just you could just be you could
sit there like your background area
looks beautiful you look like you know
what you're doing a guy who obsessed
with driving obviously if I just look at
your background
so you could even just sit there and do
it especially those multiple choice ones
oh yeah totally yeah and just splash up
in New Jersey something on the side like
you know put it on in the editing
it's it's given the value to the
consumer they're searching for it you
want to give it to them yeah and then
that promotes what you're ultimately
selling a course right or a program
faster driver's test first time
yeah
so again for this it's totally different
than most YouTube advice I would give
because people don't want to subscribe
and you already got 200 000 subscribers
but people don't why am I going to
subscribe to a how to drive like it's a
moment in time for people's lives oh no
exactly no you're spot on you're spot on
because they're there sort of six to
eight weeks
you know 80 of them and then they're
gone
yeah the only people who would really
subscribe and watch are other Driving
School teachers who want to see the
latest content that you're coming up
with so even if somebody does subscribe
great A year later they're not watching
a Content anymore hopefully because
they've passed the test
although I failed my driving test I
think five times so I could have used
your program there's always something
not the written I aced the written the
actual driving I got too nervous and I
just messed up a bunch of times and I
could have used your help and guidance
on that
[ __ ] I would have put I wouldn't have
trusted you like oh this guy's from
where is he from
oh he's American okay you can't help me
yeah right I would have typed Ontario
not knowing that's probably pretty much
the same across Canada
awesome thank you lady Lexi also failed
her driver's test so there you go
perfect
cool you only you only fail if you give
up
and don't go and get your license if
you've got your license you didn't fail
you were just unsuccessful at that
attempt
I I uh I failed
to the point where on my last one I
failed and then they they gave me an ex
uh my next test was going to be past the
expiry date of my
my whatever my like my license is going
to expire but my test goes afterwards so
they gave me a temporary license just
for that day so that I could drive there
and do the do the exam and luckily I
passed that and I've never been in like
accidents or tickets or anything like
I'm a great driver I don't know why I
couldn't it was anxiety or pressure of
having somebody with me was it intro
uh I went a little outside the city I
learned because they're they're a lot
harder in the big city where if you go a
little outside they're nicer and
friendlier so I slowly learned that
you know what else I learned a couple of
weeks ago was that if you go to Toronto
the test is probably only 10 minutes
it's like if you go to New York City
it's only eight minutes
you go to some place outside the city
that's a small town they got all the
time in the world your test would be
like 45 minutes long
okay well I I mean I passed outside the
city so I'll take that they were nicer
but I could have used all your hacks
luckily I got my test and uh I'm 41 and
don't have to worry about doing that
again but we want to get to my 70s and
I'm forced to take them again then I'll
I'll actually look under 80 your other
mandatory test yeah that could be
another that's another category like
seniors and and also like kids of the
seniors trying to research how do I help
my 80 year old father or grandfather
pass this test if there's any specifics
around that I'd look at that as content
too
if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love